Since 1984, Wes Craven's A Nightmare on Elm
Street has sent shockwaves through pop culture,
mostly thanks to the unkillable psycho villain
Freddy Krueger.
But who was the man behind the makeup wielding
that nightmarish claw?
His name is Robert Englund, and he's done
much more than just play a quippy child killer
in increasingly cheesy horror movies.
In real life, Englund is a respected character
actor, and he's been keeping busy since his
last turn in the role in Freddy vs. Jason.
Here's everything you need to know about the
man behind the monster who haunts your dreams.
Horror never ends
As Freddy Krueger, Englund's very face became
synonymous with the horror genre.
To this day, he still lands roles in horror
movies around the globe, with a new project,
the puppet-based thriller Abruptio, expected
for release in 2019.
After doing more than 75 movies in his career,
he estimates at least 20 of them are horror.
While it's been nearly two decades since he's
suited up as Freddy, genre projects are always
there for him when he needs a quick payday.
Speaking in a 2013 interview with the Chicago-area
Daily Herald, he said,
"When things get slow for me in Hollywood
[...] I can always go off to Europe and do
a movie in Italy or Spain.
This is the great gift, the happy accident
of my career.
Because horror movies, like science fiction
and action and fantasy movies, speak the international
language of cinema."
Of course, that kind of attitude means that
some movies Englund has shown up in have been
less than stellar.
He's open about the fact that he'll sometimes
take jobs just for the paycheck.
If you thought he signed on to Strippers vs.
Werewolves for artistic reasons, well, think
again.
Gamer dreams
Englund did more than just voice act for 2010's
Call of Duty: Black Ops.
For a bonus mode in that game, he also showed
up as himself.
Teaming up with Danny Trejo, Sarah Michelle
Gellar, and Michael Rooker, he appeared as
a playable character in a zombie-themed level
named "Call of the Dead."
An insane interactive love letter to horror
cinema, the level is a treat for fans of the
genre who also happen to like playing first-person
shooters.
"Watch out zombies, I'm a comin' for ya!"
Englund's favorite part about the role was
the reaction he received from the children
in his family, too young to remember Freddy
Krueger at the height of his powers.
"Freddy's kind of old to them, it's sort of
old school to them, ya know, and uh, now that
Uncle Robert is working on Call of Duty he's
cool again"
Con jobs
Some actors grow to resent the fandoms that
pop up around their most famous characters,
but if Englund has any frustration with being
associated with Freddy, he doesn't show it.
As he puts it,
"Freddy will get top billing in my obituary."
Instead, he makes an effort to meet fans whenever
he's able, particularly around the lucrative
Halloween season.
For years, Englund has generally done three
or four appearances a year, some at Comic
Con-style conventions, and some at specific
screenings of Nightmare on Elm Street movies.
They're good occasions to meet the man behind
the makeup, pose for a photo, or get something
signed.
In the movies, messages from Freddy were heart-stopping
moments that portended death; you can have
a lot more fun with a nice autograph.
Freddy presents...
Englund also stepped behind the camera, starting
with a horror film called 976-EVIL, which
was released in 1988 while he was still making
movies as the dreaded Fred Krueger.
Years later, he also directed the 2008 horror
comedy Killer Pad.
Beyond those original projects, Englund has
also taken a retrospective look at his own
career, starring in and helping to produce
Nightmares in the Makeup Chair, a documentary
about the long hours of work it takes to bring
Freddy to life through practical makeup effects.
In a statement about the movie, Englund called
the doc,
"[...] my love letter to the Nightmare on
Elm Street series and to practical makeup."
"YOU'RE ALL MY CHILDREN NOW, PIGGIES.
HAHAHAHAHA!"
Reboot rebuttal
While the quality of each installment varies,
the Nightmare On Elm Street movies all possess
a certain charm, except, of course, for the
2010 remake.
Critics were cold to the overly-serious treatment
of the material, and so was the actor who
made the films iconic.
While he had nothing but kind things to say
about the reboot's cast, Englund says the
remake missed the mark, partly by going in
a much darker direction than series fans were
used to.
In his opinion, the movie needed a happy-go-lucky
element.
"I think that that ingredient was stepped
on by their reshoots which kind of set it
deeper into the curse of Freddy by the time
the movie began."
Guest star Robert Englund
Even though his most famous role caked him
behind layers of monstrous makeup, Englund
is still effective as a plain-faced character
actor.
It's work he's kept up steadily following
the end of his involvement in the Nightmare
franchise, appearing in shows like Hawaii
5-0, Supernatural, and Criminal Minds, with
guest spots often playing off his notoriety
as the infamous Springwood Slasher.
While Englund's personal nightmare may be
over, the man of your dreams is still with
us, still working, and never too far away
from prime time.